rodeada de celulares y seguidores así
llegó la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes al congreso
estadounidense daría uno de los
discursos que cierra un importante
capítulo de su vida ceder el liderazgo
de los demócratas en la cámara baja para
la próxima legislatura después del
anuncio los demócratas reaccionaron
a Nancy pelosi mi querida buena y
cercana amiga Gracias gracias por ser tú
Gracias por dedicar tu vida al servicio
público Gracias por enseñarnos tanto
Gracias por inspirarnos a todos ha sido
un honor trabajar contigo
la renuncia de pelosia Liderazgo
representa un cambio generacional dentro
de la dirección del partido el anuncio
lo hizo tras la obtención de la mayoría
por parte de los republicanos en la
cámara sus colegas ya la ven como una
personalidad histórica
[Música]
ella probablemente pasa libros como
labradora más impactante en la historia
de la cámara de representantes de
Estados Unidos ha sido una inspiración
para las mujeres los jóvenes y las
personas de color en todo el país
aún no se sabe a ciencia cierta quien la
sustituirá Aunque un hombre resuena
entre varios a quien jeffreys un
defensor de los derechos de las minorías
necesitamos lidiar con el racismo
sistemático en Estados Unidos y podemos
comenzar con el cáncer de la brutalidad
policial jeffreys sería el primer
afroamericano en encabezar la agrupación
azul en la cámara de representantes que
el próximo 30 de noviembre elegirá a su
nuevo líder